Guten Morgen Andre.
Morgen anregen. Guten Morgen Tim.
Heute, heute ohne Linus oder was?
Mit ohne Linus aber mit anderen Menschen.
Ah, okay.
Und zwar Lokbuchnetz, Politik sechsundsechzig, die sechsundsechzigste Ausgabe,
schon angedroht. Mit ohne Linus, Linus ist in der Versenkung verschwunden.
Im Schlamm.
Im Schlamm irgendwo in der Diaspora im äh tiefen Edgeland, da wo sich Bits und Bites noch gute Nacht sagen.
Wenn's überhaupt Edge gibt.
Oder Bits oder Bites. Ja, das ist äh das Drama
Aber dafür bist du ja da und äh bringst hier die Themenlage auf Vordermann
wir hatten dich ja schon einige Male von daher sollte auch der geneigte Stammhörer nicht sonderlich überrascht sein, aber wir haben noch gleich noch ein ganzes Paket von zusätzlichen äh Gästen mitgebracht,
unter anderem begrüßen wir hier im Studio, den Benjamin, Benjamin Bergemann, hallo.
Hi.
Bis hier sozusagen gleich die Verstärkung.
Auch Netzpolitik-Workout.
Genau, was muss man zu Benjamin sagen?
Das machen wir dann später.
Ja, kann man ja jetzt sagen.
Ja, ich bin Benjamin, ich schreibe für Netzpolitik dot org, ähm vor allem über die EU-Datenschutzreform, über die wir auch gleich quatschen wollen. Ja, und sonst studiere ich hier in Berlin Politikwissenschaft. Genau.
Okay, also volle volle Netzpolitik äh Punkt org Anschlags,
Vorbereitungen. Gut. So und außerdem haben wir uns dann auch gleich für unser äh erstes Thema noch einen Gast äh übers Telefon reingeholt. Wir sagen äh hallo zu Johannes.
Johannes, Johannes Scheller, du bist äh ja zu äh schneller Berühmtheit erlangt in der letzten Zeit, weil du den Fehler gemacht hast, als erster auf den Petitionsknopf zu zu klicken,
Ähm ja, was äh was hast du denn, was ist denn passiert?
Ja, ich habe äh die in der letzten Woche ganz gut durchgestartete Petitionen zur gesetzlichen Verankerung der Netzneutralität auf der Petitionsplattform vom Bundestag gestartet, denn ein bisschen Werbung dafür gemacht und bin jetzt grad dabei, überrascht zu sein, wie gut das geklappt hat.
Ja, die magische äh fünfzigtausend äh Unterstützermarke ist bereits gerissen. Das bedeutet, dass sie sich äh auch schon mal auf ein kleines Referat im Bundestag vorbereiten kannst, auch wenn das wahrscheinlich noch eine Weile dauern wird, ne?
Ähm überraschenderweise habe ich gestern die Info bekommen, dass sich die SPD dafür einsetzt, dass es noch im nächsten Monat passiert.
Oh, aha, okay, interessant. Kannst du vielleicht nochmal kurz so ein bisschen was zu dir sagen, was was dich dazu gebracht hat, da dich überhaupt zu engagieren? Was so dein Hintergrund ist?
Ja, also zu mir, ich bin noch neunzehn Physikstudent in Tübingen und äh
bin seit ein paar Jahren an Netzpolitik interessiert. Ähm
und hab mich dabei immer für die Netzneutralität zur am meisten interessiert, war für mich da so das wichtigste Thema und
Jetzt nachdem ich gesehen habe, welchen Erfolg äh Malte Götz mit seiner Petition zur Drossel kommen hatte und ich,
dann die Themen überschneiden sich ja doch schon ein bisschen.
Vielleicht ist jetzt auch der richtige Moment, mal was für die Netzneutralität zu tun
und hab dann einfach mal 'ne Petition formuliert, abgeschickt und gedacht, ja, vielleicht kann ich ja was erreichen damit.
Die andere Petition ist ja bei Change Punkt ORG glaube ich äh geführt, was äh auch eine recht populäre Plattform ist so für allerlei gesellschaftsveränderndes äh Zeug, aber du hast dich ja ganz bewusst an die Bundestags äh Plattform gewendet.
Ja genau, ähm denn das auf Change Punkt ORG ist zwar auch eine gute Sache, aber letztendlich äh,
man dann hin zur Telekom, übergibt da seine Liste mit zweihunderttausend Unterzeichnern, äh bekommt wie Malte vielleicht noch ein Gespräch mit
Vorstandsmitgliedern der Telekom und letztendlich muss man dann wieder Malte rausgehen und sagen, ich glaube nichts nicht, dass ich was bewirken konnte mit mit Neutralität lässt sich kein Geld verdienen und äh das,
denn bei dem ganzen symbolischen und ich hatte halt die kleine Hoffnung, dass die Edition doch irgendwie an der Gesetzgebung was verändern können.
Hast du die immer noch?
Ich hab sie sogar, die ist bei mir sogar stärker geworden,
irgendwie ich hab gemerkt welche Reaktionen da aus Parteien auch kommen und die sind gar nicht mal so abgeneigt.
Was kommt da so für Reaktionen?
Klar von Piraten, Linken und Grünen kommt deutlich Unterstützung, die wollen das ja teilweise auch schon länger machen, aber interessanterweise habe ich zum Beispiel von der,
netzpolitischen Gruppe innerhalb der CSU, also auf Twitter unter CSU net äh,
mitbekommen, dass auch die meine Petition verbreitet und haben mit dem Hinweis, wir unterstützen diese Petition und äh da war ich dann doch etwas überrascht
und sehe jetzt eigentlich ganz optimistisch da nach vorne, dass da vielleicht tatsächlich mal was draus werden könnte.
Der Prozess ist ja so, wenn die fünfzigtausend geschafft sind, kann sich der Petitionsausschuss, ich habe den mal als so ziemlich der unwichtigste Ausschuss im ganzen Bundestag bezeichnet,
kann der sich entscheiden, dich einzuladen. Äh mittlerweile mit der Aufmerksamkeit bei dem Thema ist das, glaube ich, nicht unwahrscheinlich, dass die dich wirklich einladen,
jetzt hast du tatsächlich schon Signale gehört, das könnte schon demnächst noch vor der Wahl passieren.
Ja genau, mir hat gestern die SPD-Bundestagsfraktion geschrieben
und ähm die haben mir geschrieben, dass sie sich dafür einsetzen werden, dass die dass ich tatsächlich eingeladen werde zu einer öffentlichen Sitzung und dass die am einzigen noch verbleibenden Termin vor der Sommerpause stattfindet. Das wäre Ende Juni
und ähm die haben mich drum gebeten, dass ich,
die ob Leute von den anderen Bundestagsfraktionen im Ausschuss mal anschreiben soll und denen allen sagen soll, hey, setzt euch auch mal dafür ein, dass ich im Juni noch vorbeikommen kann.
Cool, bist du schon aufgeregt?
So langsam kommt's.
Ja, was was würdest du denn sagen, ist so eigentlich die ähm stechendste Argumentation, die an der Stelle auch wirken könnte.
Ähm habe ich auch schon länger drüber nachgedacht, aber ich denke mal,
Widerstand hat man ja am ehesten aus Reihen der Regierungskoalition zu erwarten
mit dem Argument, dass das doch bitte der Markt regeln soll, die Netzneutralität
und ich denke, gerade bei den äh Leuten, denen muss man klar machen, wie wichtig ein freies und offenes Netz für die Wirtschaft in Deutschland ist. Wenn ich mir angucke, dass Philipp Rößler gerade die letzten Wochen
im Silicon Valley war und,
Start-ups herholen wollte, äh wenn er damit sowas kommt, wie gesetzlich gesicherter Netzneutralität hat, hat er da bessere Chancen, dass von denen tatsächlich sich auch jemand für Deutschland interessiert, glaube ich.
Aber das regelt doch der Markt.
Tut er ja nicht, wie die Telekom zeigt, wenn die Telekom als Markt beherrschendes Unternehmen in Deutschland sich das erlauben kann, äh,
das äh bei ihrem Drosselplänen äh gleichzeitig die Netzneutralität zu verletzen, dann hat der Markt versagt.
Ja, kleiner Zwischenstand, die Petition wurde am Dienstag freigeschaltet, glaube ich,
und hat am Freitag die fünfzigtausend geknackt, ist jetzt bei siebzigtausend und,
das geht auch noch, das mit Zeichnen bis zum achtzehnten Juni, also das ist gerade mal eine Woche alt und kann gerne weiter mitgezeichnet werden.
Ja genau, ich freue mich da auch, wenn noch viele Leute mitmachen, denn je mehr jetzt dabei sind, desto deutlicher ist das Signal an die Politik, also.
Bei Zensursula hatten wir hundertvierunddreißigtausend Unterzeichner und das hat äh Franziska damals im Bundestagsausschuss schön gesagt, dass es zweimal das Olympiastadion, für das ist hier gerade spreche,
schon Eindruck, große Zahlen äh gegenüber Politikern damit zu argumentieren.
Ja
Na gut, ich meine, man muss ihnen da nichts vormachen. Natürlich ist äh der Wert der Petition vor allem erstmal eine mediale, ne? Und dass sich Oppositionsparteien äh im Vorwahlkampf äh auf alles äh stürzen
in irgendeiner Form als Beschädigung der Regierung wahrgenommen werden kann, ist auch klar. Nicht, dass man dann immer sofort davon ausgehen
dass sie das zum Mittelpunkt ihres Wahlkampfs äh geschweige denn eines möglichen Regierungsprogramms machen. Aber ich denke, solchen Illusionen gibst du dich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt hin, ne?
Nee, auf keinen Fall, also es ist auch kein Zufall, dass ich bisher bei mir nur die Oppositionsparteien mit Unterstützung gemeldet haben und die Regierung da eher abwartend ist.
Na und CSU äh Zähne.
Ja, ja, tatsächlich, ähm.
Hast du mal mit denen denn mal, ich meine, äh was für einen Kontakt gab's da? Die haben nur gesagt, wenn.
Gab's auf es gab auf Twitter kurz 'ne Konversation zwischen uns aber ich werd den Kontakt zu denen jetzt auch noch intensivieren denn,
da so ein bisschen auch drauf festzunageln auf deren Zusage.
Ich meine gut, wie wie groß deren äh äh Macht im Parlament ist, hat sich ja bei den letzten Abstimmungen auch gezeigt. Da haben dann halt die zwei, drei Leute äh dagegen gestimmt und dann äh der Rest hat das irgendwie geflissentlich ignoriert, wenn's mal wieder um
netzpolitische Themen geht.
Ja
Denke ich, wäre das mal ganz interessant ähm mal deren Argumentation auch äh zu hören, gerade im Hinblick auf den Wirtschaftsaspekt.
Stimmt ja.
Die sind ja alle für Netzneutralität. Die sagen das ja auch, das muss unbedingt Netzneutralität geben. Nur die sagen, wir können nicht in den Markt eingreifen, der wird das schon regeln.
Ist deren Sichtweise.
Ich muss sagen, ich bin ganz mir so ein kleiner Stein vom Herzen gefallen, als die fünfzigtausend geknackt wurde, äh als digitalen, als ich die Zahlen gesehen habe, dann Johannes, wir waren ja auch schon ziemlich am Anfang,
Dienstag quasi gleich in Kontakt,
und wir waren noch ziemlich unter dem Eindruck der Leistungsschutzrecht Petition, die ja wo man grandios wo dann alle Netzinstitutionen noch mit aufgesprungen sind in letzter Minute und trotzdem grandios gescheitert sind,
hatte die dann auch ein Artikel von Metronout geschickt, Petitionen sind für 'n Arsch.
Tatsächlich, ja, äh kann das auch nach hinten losgehen, wenn's eben heißt, die ganze Netzcommunity unterstützt das jetzt und da sind trotzdem nur weniger äh Unterzeichner als die Piratenparteimitglieder hat.
Bin bin froh, dass das jetzt doch geklappt hat. Hätte ich nicht erwartet, äh aber anscheinend geht das äh das Thema Drosselung. Und damit dann einher auch Netzneutralität äh viele Leute was einen und bewegt sie. Finde ich gut.
Ja. Ähm du bist ja Student, ne, Johannes? Ähm was studierst du?
Physik in Tübingen.
Und ähm hast du so äh in in deinem Jahrgang so in deinem deiner Altersgruppe da so den Eindruck, dass das Thema äh verfängt.
Ähm ich bin relativ überrascht davon, wie viele sich jetzt nach
ich da so ein bisschen involviert bin, wie viele sie jetzt für das Thema interessieren
die sich von mir das erklären lassen oder dies teilweise auch vielleicht schon gehört hatten und jetzt aber richtig dabei sind äh das zu unterstützen. Da bin ich echt,
ziemlich positiv überrascht, wie das läuft.
Hm. Welche Unterstützung kannst du denn noch gebrauchen?
Ich kann Unterstützung aus der nicht Internet Presse gebrauchen. Also wir müssen's immer noch schaffen, das Thema weiter aus den Netzgemeinde rauszutragen
und jeder Bericht in irgendeiner Zeitung, im Radio, im Fernsehen oder sonst wo, über das Thema hilft uns da ein kleines Stück
denke ich, dass nochmal jemand weiß, was Netzneutralität ist, der vorher damit nix anfangen konnte, denn es betrifft ja einfach nicht nur die Netzgemeinden, das betrifft ja jeden
letztendlich ja gesellschaftspolitik und nicht nur Netzpolitik.
Glaube genau dafür ist dann so eine Anhörung gut, wenn tatsächlich klassische Totholz und TV-Medien
über ein Bundestagsthema berichten und damals hat das Franziska echt super gemacht, weil der Vorratsdatenspeicherung und bei ACDA hat das leider nicht ganz so gut funktioniert, aber ich glaube bei diesem Thema haben wir eine sehr große Chance, äh das in die klassischen Medien weiterhin zu bringen. Äh Drosselcom ist ja schon da und
Weil du merkst ja auch selber, die Anfragen der Medien nehmen zu, oder?
Ja, ich hatte am Freitag dann mal irgendwann den Eindruck, es wird weniger, aber das war nur das Wochenende. Die Journalisten machen da auch frei. Äh das ist jetzt gestern wieder richtig abgegangen und geht gerade auch noch weiter.
Das geht tatsächlich durchs Thema Drossel kommen so steil, also einerseits
ganz gut ist, wenn man damit jetzt Aufmerksamkeit hat, andererseits muss ich eigentlich in jedem Interview, jeden Beitrag erklären, dass ich nicht die zweite Petition gegen die Telekom gestartet habe, sondern dass
die Themen sich nur überschneiden und es gar nicht um die Drosselung an sich geht bei mir.
Also ich bin schon ehrlich gesagt ziemlich überrascht, wie lang das Thema sich überhaupt gehalten hat, äh weil eigentlich alle so ein bisschen damit gerechnet haben, so, na, okay, alles klar, dann gibt's ein bisschen Aufreger, dann schreiben sie in die Verträge und das war's. So, ne, aber jetzt ist ja allein schon dieses Drosselcom nehmen
scheint ja schon äh einen nachhaltigen Imageschaden äh nach sich zu ziehen. Insofern äh könnte das vielleicht nochmal ganz spannend werden. Meine Frage war auch noch so ein bisschen in die Richtung äh gedacht, äh ob du jetzt konkret selbst auch noch irgendeine Unterstützung äh erfahren müsstest,
in der Vorbereitung da auf deinen Bundestagsshowdown.
Ähm bestimmt, also äh ich werde mich mit
und den anderen Jungs nochmal in Kontakt setzen, damit ich noch ein bisschen inhaltlich gebrieft bin und mich auf die Gegenargumente alle einstellen kann und die hoffentlich dann irgendwie entkräften kann. Äh ich werde mich relativ
bald dann auch mal dran setzen, wenn ich tatsächlich weiß, was ich da eingeladen werde, dass ich mir dann Gedanken mache, wie gehe ich da vor? Und ich denke, da kann ich auch noch hier aus der ganzen Szene, um die Unterstützung gebrauchen.
Kriegen wir hin, da bleiben wir ja in Kontakt, äh telefonieren dann auch später noch dazu.
Richtig.
Okay, Johannes, vielen Dank.
Gerne.
Ja, danke für die Petition und danke fürs dranbleiben und danke für äh jetzt zuschalten, genau.
Genau. Alles klar. Dann mach's gut, ne.
Ja, ich danke euch. Ja, ihr auch. Tschüss. Tschüss.
Tschüss.
Eine kleine Anmerkung habe ich noch zu Netzneutralität. Ähm nachdem die während der Republika die Verbraucherschutzzentrale NRW.
Drossel kommen hätte ich fast gesagt. Die Telekom äh abgemahnt hat, dass sie das mit den Tarifen doch mal sein zu lassen hat, sonst werden sie verklagt,
Mal gucken, was das bringt.
Jetzt in der, ich glaube, vorletzten Woche die Konferenz der Verbraucherschutzminister aller Bundesländer einstimmig beschlossen, auf ihre Konferenz eben eine gesetzliche Verankerung der Netzneutralität zu fordern.
Anscheinend haben die das letztes Jahr schon mal getan,
Ähm das ist so ein bisschen tricky, weil ich habe bisher offiziell nur die Pressemitteilungen und ich darf irgendwie die Protokolle da daraus noch nicht zitieren, weil irgendwie die brauchen noch, das sind Beamte, die brauchen noch zwei, drei Wochen, äh die das online gestellt haben oder so,
aber ich tue das jetzt einfach mal. Die Verbraucherschutzministerkonferenz weist insbesondere aufgrund der äh von der Telekom angekündigten Tarifänderungen auf die dringende Notwendigkeit hin,
zum Schutz von Verbraucherinnen und Verbrauchern ein sachlich ungerechtfertigtes Verlangsamen benachteiligten oder blockieren von Diensten im Internet untersagt werden muss,
Dazu fordern sie eine gesetzliche Verankerung, wenden sich insbesondere,
Bundesverbraucherschutzministerium von unserer guten Frau Eigner, die wahrscheinlich schon ihren Telekom-Vertrag gekündigt hat. Äh und fordern.
Ja, man fragt sich, ob überhaupt noch irgendwelche Verträge übrig bleiben bei Frau Eigner, ne?
Genau, das wollte ich noch ein interessantes Tipp. Die haben das anscheinend letztes Jahr schon mal gemacht, aber dieses Jahr äh wiederholt die Gruppen, die das fordern, mehreren sich letzte Woche ging's auch so ein Paper von ARD und ZDF rum,
das hatten wir tatsächlich schon vor über einem Jahr auf echtes Netz D E stehen, weil so alt ist das Paper auch schon, die sind,
schon seit März, seit vor den ersten Leaks der Ankündigung der Telekom dabei, das zu updaten,
Das ist aber so weit ich weiß noch nicht, das dürfte aber in nächster Zeit auch kommen,
aber auch ARD und ZDF als Inhalte anbiete, wie die Metaebene, wie Netzpolitik, ORG äh betrifft natürlich äh.
Ja, das finde ich ganz interessant, dass so so ein so ein gewisses Verständnis auf einmal einzusetzen scheint, dass da jetzt wirklich eine aktive Benachteiligung beziehungsweise Bevorteilung weniger gegen Geld äh stattfindet
und ähm dass das eben auch wirklich relevante Dimensionen hat, ne. Ja. Kommen wir sonst noch was zu dem Thema beizutragen gerade?
Da gibt's so viel, das wird uns aber noch eine Weile erhalten bleiben, insofern.
Gut, dann schreib mir doch mal äh voran und nimm hier so einen anderen Dauerbrenner äh in Augenschein,
Die EU-Datenschutzverordnung, der immerwährende äh Kampf gegen die äh Änderung auf EU-Ebene rund um den Datenschutz, von dem wir hier schon viel gehört haben
Benjamin, dein Thema ist das auch so ein bisschen, ne?
Genau, ich äh blogge dazu auf Netzpolitik dot org.
Und was ist so der Stand der Dinge.
Ja läuft Scheiße.
Ja
Um es mal so zu sagen. Im Januar hattet ihr ja die Kirsten da oder zugeschaltet von Edri,
und da waren wir gerade in der Phase, hat der Berichterstatter Jan Philipp Albrecht gerade seinen Bericht vorgestellt und dann ging es eigentlich erst in diese ganzen Ausschussabstimmungen
und in den Ausschuss Abstimmungen hat sich ja dann erst gezeigt, wie dort Lobbyistenanträge eingebracht wurden ins Parlament.
Und da ist es ja erst losgegangen, was Kiki also damals angedeutet hat im Podcast, wow, hier kommt bald eine Lobbywelle, das ist dann auch wirklich,
mit einer Vehemenz passiert und da hatten wir auch ja ganz kurz auch Medienaufmerksamkeit da. Weil diese Lobby-Plug-Geschichte, da wurde das ja ganz gut thematisiert eine Weile
Jetzt haben wir das Problem immer noch, wir sind in einer heißen Phase der Datenschutzreform, wir sind kurz vor der Abstimmung des sogenannten Federführenden Ausschusses im Parlament, der die Meinung des Europäischen Parlaments zur Datenschutzreform festlegt,
nur die Aufmerksamkeit ist weg.
Warum ist sie weg?
Ja
Ich weiß warum. Weißt du, abstrakt ist, am Januar hat Kiki von tausendfünfhundert Änderungsanträgen berichtet,
und das ist ein mega Stapelpapier. Jetzt sind's viertausend. Also das Thema wird nicht weniger komplex, sondern.
Oh Gott.
Noch komplexer. Jetzt sind wirklich die harten Detailfragen an den einzelnen Emmentments, wie werden bestimmte äh Sachen definiert? Das sind das sind teilweise hier ähm ja bisschen juristische,
und ein sehr detaillierte Fragen über die sich da gerade ziemlich gefetzt wird, sowohl im Parlament als auch äh im Rat.
Ja, beziehungsweise es ist, glaube ich, auch so, dass wir's hier nicht mit einer klaren Ja- oder nein-Entscheidung zu tun haben. Es ist nicht wie bei Acta, wo wir sagen,
boah, wir sind irgendwie gegen dieses scheiß da, sondern es gibt dort einzelne Punkte in der Verordnung, die sind gut. Es gibt einzelne äh Punkte, die sind schlecht,
Und jetzt müssen wir uns entscheiden, welche Punkte finden wir gut, welche finden wir schlecht, welche Akteure stehen auf unserer Seite, welche Akteure stehen gegen uns, also gegen die Netzgemeinde TM oder so.
Ja. Gibt's denn da überhaupt Einigkeit da drüber, wie man sozusagen zu den einzelnen Eingaben steht.
Ich glaube schon. Ich würde sagen, wenn man jetzt nicht gerade zur äh Post Privacy
gehört denn äh besteht da schon eine gewisse Einigung. Ähm dass man halt sagt, okay, wir finden den Kommissionsvorschlag eigentlich ganz cool so, wie er ist. Er könnte an einigen Stellen
noch verbessert werden, aber prinzipiell ist der ganz okay. So und was jetzt gekommen ist, äh im Parlament hat,
den Kommissionsvorschlag nicht ein bisschen verbessert, sondern es hat den Kommissionsvorschlag extrem abgeschwächt und da besteht, glaube ich, schon Einigkeit, dass da Lobbyinteressen im Spiel sind und das einfach,
Kacke ist, wie's da läuft grade.
Ist denn das so, dass es also du sagst, abgeschwächt äh ich hätte jetzt auch fast äh vermuten können, so durch diese ganzen Änderungen,
wer das Ding vielleicht in irgendeiner Form sogar schon komplett gedreht worden, dass es am Ende eine ganz andere Aussagekraft hat als äh vor, also ich meine verschlechtert sich irgendetwas im Vergleich zu der
gesetzlichen, jetzigen Ist-Situationen oder verschlechtert sich nur etwas relativ zu dem ursprünglichen Vorschlag.
Ähm ich würde sagen, dass ich,
auch die jetzige Ist-Situation verschlechtert, denn wir haben's ja hier mit einer Verordnung zu tun, was Linus und Kiki im Januar auch ganz gut hier rausgearbeitet haben. Eine Verordnung geht in allen siebenundzwanzig EU-Staaten. Es ist keine Richtlinie, eine Richtlinie
Da gießen die Länder das nochmal in nationale Gesetze, sondern diese Verordnung gilt sofort. Wenn jetzt ähm eine schlechte Verordnung kommt, haben wir also,
direkt und in Deutschland scheiß Datenschutzgesetze. Und das ist eigentlich auch genau,
Effekt, den wir eigentlich nicht haben wollten, weil's ja auch zu einer gewissen Euroskepsis beiträgt, dass letztlich wieder die Recht haben, die damals gesagt haben, boah nein, da kommt so ein Ding aus Europa,
wir haben hier unseren geilen Deutschen Datenschutz. Was wir eigentlich wollten, war ein Durchsetzungsdefizite verhindern, weil eben Facebook, in Irland sitzt,
und wir ähm ja und wir Facebook halt nicht belangen können. Und jetzt,
Aber jetzt haben genau diese Leute kriegen jetzt Wasser auf die Mühlen und können sagen, ja, seht ihr, da kam wieder Scheiße aus Brüssel.
Klingt ja auch ein bisschen deprimiert.
Es klingt ein bisschen deprimierend, aber ja, ich würde, ich würde
eben äh nicht der Sache aufsitzen, dass es so ultra komplex ist, sondern wir haben auf Netzpolitik dot org bei der digitalen Gesellschaft versucht, konsequent dieses Thema ein bisschen herunterzubrechen,
zu sagen, okay, hier sind die wichtigsten zehn Punkte,
Hier sind die wichtigsten inzwischen sind wir sogar bei fünf Punkten. Es gibt neuen Bericht von Bürgerrechtsorganisation. Der Bericht ist auf fünf Punkte herunter.
Und wenn man sich das mal anschaut, dann kann man, glaube ich, da auch ganz gut am Stammtisch drüber debattieren,
Weil man nämlich einfach sagt, okay, in einem Satz, in dieser Verordnung geht's dadrum, wir wollen,
wissen, was da läuft bei der Datenverarbeitung. Wir wollen vorher gefragt werden und wir wollen aus der Geschichte auch wieder rauskommen. Wenn ich keinen Bock mehr habe, will ich den Anbieter wechseln,
und äh will, dass meine Daten gelöscht werden. Punkt. So kann man das Ding einfach zusammenfassen.
Und wenn jetzt natürlich an allen Ecken rumgesägt wird, dann kann man dann kann man sich ja immer diese Vorschläge angucken und dann finde ich's schon relativ offensichtlich, wenn da steht, ähm,
Ja, ich soll eben nicht vorher gefragt werden, wenn's sich um pseudonymisierte Daten handelt, was auch immer das sein soll,
dann soll dich vorher nicht gefragt werden, dann ist es doch eindeutig,
Dass ähm dass diese Vorschläge industriefreundlich sind und da irgendwie versucht wird, ein Schlupfloch einzubauen.
Und deshalb, ich finde das gar nicht so schwer. Man kann eigentlich könnte man dieses Thema schon ganz gut polemisieren. Sowohl inhaltlich als auch politisch, weil politisch,
haben wir diesen ähm finde ich diese einmalige Gelegenheit gehabt oder haben die immer noch,
wie's auch durch die Lobby-Plug-Affäre war. Wir können mal sehen, wie funktioniert dieses Brüssel eigentlich? Da kommen Leute ins Parlament, schlagen in Parlamentariern vor,
schreibt mal das da rein, schreibt mal das da rein die entscheiden sich,
So, wir hatten jetzt ähm Entscheidungen, die sehr industrielastig waren, was ja auch kein Wunder ist, wenn da irgendwie zehntausend Datenschutzunfreundliche Leute im Parlament rumrennen, gegen drei Datenschutzfreundliche Advocy Manager.
Genau und ähm das ist finde ich auch eine Sache, die man noch mal stärker polemisieren könnte, wo man einfach sieht, ey Leute, da haben jetzt,
Firmen
Recht bekommen. Wir haben's in den Ausschussabstimmungen gesehen. Da wurden eins zu eins die ähm Vorschläge von Amazon, der Direktmarketing Industrie und Co übernommen. Wirklich eins zu eins.
Und genau so 'ne einfachen Sachen wie ich eben beschrieben habe wo dann steht,
ja äh ich muss jetzt nicht mehr gefragt werden unter den und den Voraussetzungen, ob meine Daten verarbeitet werden. Das ist aber jetzt so eine Ausnahme.
Ja, was heißt denn äh wurden äh übernommen, also beziehst dich jetzt sozusagen auch wirklich auf auch auf Ergebnisse, die du aus Lobby-Plug ähm herausgefallen sind?
Erstmal, das finde ich mal sowieso immer ganz interessant, ob das Tool als solches jetzt auch Wirkungen gezeigt hat. Du mixst Andre, musst laut nicken.
Ich hatte gedacht, Benjamin.
Ihr könnt auch gerne beide äh laut nicken. Ähm und wer hat's dann übernommen?
Also ich meine, wer hat es, also wir reden ja jetzt noch nicht von einer finalen Entscheidung, sondern wir reden ja davon, dass einzelne Fraktionen es übernehmen für ihre Anänderungsanträge et cetera.
Genau. Ich glaube, ähm ich habe jetzt schon viel gequatscht. Ich glaube, wie systematisieren die Sache jetzt nochmal. Also, seid Kiki im Januar hier war, hatten wir Ausschussabstimmungen im Parlament. Dieser Ausschüsse haben ihre Meinung gegeben,
Das also ähm es wird halt gesagt, eigentlich ist für Datenschutz ist der
Innenausschuss zuständig, aber es ist ja auch ein Verbraucherthema. Es ist ja auch ein Rechtsthema und so weiter, deshalb müssen auch diese Ausschüsse wenigstens angehört werden und ihre Meinung sagen,
und genau diesen Prozess hatten wir jetzt und da fiel und das viel genau in diese Lobby-Plack Phase. In diesen Meinungsgebenden Ausschüssen Wohnen halt genau diese industriefreundlichen Anträge auf den Tisch gebracht
und es wurde auch für die abgestimmt, weil die wurden von konservativen Abgeordneten eingebracht,
und ähm die konservativen Abgeordneten zusammen mit den Liberalen haben im Europäischen Parlament eine Mehrheit, natürlich auch in den Ausschüssen,
und so wohnen die wirklich eins zu eins übernommen und das hat Lobbyplug ganz eindeutig gezeigt.
Das heißt, auch von mehreren Ausschüssen sind jetzt schon diverse Vorschläge als Empfehlung ans Parlament gegangen. Aber wer bestimmt jetzt letztlich über den eigentlichen äh abzustimmenden Entwurf der ganzen Richtlinie.
Macht, der federführende Innenausschuss.
Ähm genau, der orientiert sich natürlich an dem, was die Ausschüsse schon vorher gesagt haben. Musste es als Meinung akzeptieren, ist aber jetzt nicht in einer alternativlosen Zwangslage, sondern kann das,
kann natürlich auch sein eigenes Ding machen. De facto ist es aber so,
ein bisschen orientieren muss und in den Ausschüssen sitzen ja auch zum Teil dieselben Abgeordneten. Eigentlich haben wir dasselbe Spiel jetzt nochmal,
Nur dass jetzt wirklich das Finale ansteht und dieser Fehler für den Innenausschuss bestimmt eben über die Position des Parlaments,
Da gibt's nicht nochmal eine großartige Parlamentsabstimmung drüber, sondern die machen das Ding fertig. Und das Komplizierte daran ist,
Wir können jetzt eben nicht bis zum Ausschuss Abstimmungstermin warten. Der Abstimmungstermin im Ausschuss soll jetzt irgendwie noch vor der Sommerpause sein.
Aber solange können wir nicht warten, denn diese Änderungsanträge inklusive der Meinung aus den anderen Ausschüssen liegen auf dem Tisch,
und da das Parlament nicht über viertausendfünfhundert Anträge abstimmen will, beziehungsweise der Ausschuss, ähm machen die im Moment kompromissverhandlungen. Da sagen die halt, okay,
meinetwegen zum Konstrukt der Einwilligung haben wir hier sechs Vorschläge, die sagen eigentlich alle dasselbe,
Also es bricht dich dann immer so runter eigentlich so auf zwei Positionen, eher Bürgerrechtsfreundliche und eine eher Bürgerrechtsunfreundliche. Man kann schon so sagen, SPD, Grüne,
versus liberale Konservative. So kann man das im Moment eigentlich ganz gut runterbrechen.
Und dann handeln die das schon mal vorher aus, dass aus diesen viertausendfünfhundert Änderungsanträgen vielleicht wieder so was weiß ich, tausend oder so wären.
Wir sind da jetzt sozusagen nur die Mitglieder des Innenausschusses der jeweiligen Parteien aktiv oder ist das wirklich so Fraktionsarbeit, die da in irgendeiner Form mit ins Spiel kommt?
Da sind die Mitglieder des Innenausschusses natürlich aktiv, vor allem die sogenannten Berichterstatter, also der Berichterstatter und die Schattenberichterstatter
untereinander. Das sind sozusagen die Gesandten ihrer Fraktion. Da sitzen dann zwei Konservative, dann natürlich der grüne Berichterstatter Jan Albrecht.
Berichterstatter.
Berichterstatter? Genau. Was ist denn das für ein geiler Begriff?
Genau. Die, das sind die, das.
Die Fraktionsdelegierten.
Genau, das sind sozusagen,
ihrer Fraktion. Es ist ziemlich, es ist ziemlich kompliziert, ja, aber im Prinzip sitzen die jetzt gerade im Hinterzimmerchen und machen genau diese Kompromisse. Wenn also der Innenausschuss zur Abstimmung geht,
stehen diese Kompromisse und damit das Gesetz eigentlich schon fest, die wissen vorher, OK, da konnten wir einen Kompromiss erzielen, OK, da konnten wir keinen Kompromiss erzielen, da wird's schiefgehen.
Und diese diese harte inhaltliche Arbeit passiert genau jetzt jeden Tag. Also wenn das dann irgendwann vor der Sommerpause abgestimmt wird,
dann ist wieder so ein Gesamtpaket von eher so, na ja, ja oder nein, wird das auch da nicht, äh sondern die grobe äh grobe Richtlinie dieses Mentementar, dieses Mentement, nein, aber dann stehen die Meinungsbildung der einzelnen,
Fraktionen
schon fest und die Mehrheitsverhältnisse stehen auch fest. Man weiß dann quasi, wie die stimmen werden. Wichtig ist, genau jetzt, zu den äh verantwortlichen Abgeordneten, die im Innenausschuss sitzen, äh denen zu sagen,
Ich bin äh für mein Recht auf Datenschutz, weil wenn's dann im Innenausschuss ist,
die Abstimmung oder erst oder danach, der Prozess geht ja dann noch weiter, dann ist es schon ziemlich spät. Genau. Dazu haben wir jetzt,
Benjamin und ich waren vor zwei Wochen in Brüssel. Äh dazu gibt's ja auch äh einige Kampagnenarbeit von äh Edri, Digies und Verwandtengruppen,
Zum einen gibt's da die Seite EU eine Gemeinschaftskampagne von,
acht oder so, also mehr als fünf europäischen Organisationen äh auf der man unter anderem schicke Postkarten mit nackten Menschen,
beschriften kann, die haben.
Es ist schon sehr bunt, ja.
Ja, die haben wir tatsächlich vor zwei Wochen schon äh EU-Abgeordneten in die Hand gedrückt und ihren Mitarbeiterinnen.
Ja
Und äh.
Ja, das macht macht teilweise Eindruck äh anders als äh so eine E-Mail. Die Idee war, dass hoffentlich manche von den Mitarbeitern zieht sich die auch ins Büro hängen,
weil sie ein bisschen schick sind. Aber diese Aktion läuft immer noch, kann man immer noch mitmachen. Entweder einen eigenen Text oder einen Vordruck drauf äh schreiben und das wird dann tatsächlich als Totbaum,
Abgeordneten und Mitarbeitern übergeben,
Äh dann haben wir von auch einigen deutschen Organisationen in der letzten Woche.
Genau, in der letzten Woche gab's einen offenen Brief an Innenminister Friedrich. Ähm
denn und jetzt kommen wir zum nächsten Problem, dieser verdammten Verordnung. Gleichzeitig verhandelt auch der ähm Ministerrat, der Ministerrat, das sind die Innen-und Justizminister, der Mitgliedsstaaten
Die sprechen genauso wie das Parlament auch über das ganze Gesetz und arbeiten sich am Kommissionsvorschlag ab.
Diese dieses diese Arbeit findet also in zwei Kammern grade statt.
Mhm. Oder Kommissionsvorschlag ist ja in dem Sinne noch unverändert und stellt noch so diese ursprüngliche äh Vision dar. Und wie steht so die ähm der Ministerrat dann dazu?
Im Ministerrat haben wir die gleiche Scheiße wie im Parlament, um es mal
sozusagen. Wir haben da, glaube ich, auch eine konservative Mehrheit. Was auch heißt, dass wir da im Ministerrat dieselben
konservativen, also sehr, sehr Datenschutzunfreundlichen und industriefreundlichen Vorschläge vorfinden. Das sind genau dieselben Vorschläge und ähm wir haben
jetzt gestern haben wir ganz spontan, haben uns die Vögelchen da ein Papier aus dem Ministerrat gebracht, denn der Ministerrat verhandelt ja eigentlich
ähm hinter verschlossenen Türen. Das heißt, beim Parlament weiß ich eigentlich grob, was da läuft, die müssen ihre Änderungsanträge zumindestens veröffentlichen.
Ministerrat macht es eben nicht,
und deshalb ist so ein Papier, wie wir's gestern bekommen haben, wo diese Länderposition ähm zu den jeweiligen ähm,
Im Text stehen, sehr, sehr wertvoll. Das haben wir gestern ähm geliebt sozusagen,
bisher noch nicht so viel Aufmerksamkeit erfahren, wahrscheinlich auch wieder, weil's sind hundertsechs Seiten und zweihundertneunundneunzig Fußnoten. Ja und,
Ich habe mir das mal, ich habe mir das mal ganz grob durchgelesen und hab's versucht, so ein bisschen auf diese Kernpunkte runterzubrechen, die wir auch die wir auch immer auf unseren Kampagnenflyern vermitteln und,
eigentlich steht da wieder derselbe konservative Kack-Scheiß drin, wie er auch im Parlament drinsteht. Das ist.
Das ist genau das gleiche wieder.
Wobei wir,
im Parlament, ja wenigstens, du hast das angesprochen, den Bonus haben, wir können da hinfahren, wir können anrufen, wir können mit den Leuten reden, die sind transparent, wer da was macht, das sind Abgeordnete, die müssen auch für ihre Bürger
äh da sein und da können wir Kampagnen machen und Postkarten hingeben und so. In den äh Ratsverhandlungen,
sind die eben Innen-und Justizminister der Länder. Das ist für Deutschland äh Schnarry ist da glaube ich ziemlich äh raus oder ruhig. Äh unser Wert der EM Friedrich,
ähm.
In Interviews immer wieder angekündigt wir wollen einen starken Datenschutz in Europa und freiwillige Selbstverpflichtung der Wirtschaft reicht nicht aus,
und wir werden auf natürlich, das sagt jeder Deutscher, keinesfalls mit der EU-Verordnung hinter geltendes deutsches Datenschutzrecht zurückfallen.
So wie Benjamin das gestern ausgearbeitet hat in den Verhandlungen, äh ist da nicht nur diese Position im Rat in der Minderheit, sondern
Deutschland und das Innenministerium vertreten, die noch nicht mal vehement, äh sondern lassen auch äh sich auf Schlupflöcher ein, die dann und das hast du vorhin gefragt, die ursprüngliche Intention,
Datenschutz in Europa zu regeln, teilweise in ihr Gegenteil verkehren, in dem dann dort steht, ja es ist wichtig auch äh wie war das Zitat,
dass die Daten frei fließen können für die Wirtschaft und so.
Mhm.
Genau. Also man muss sich,
Nochmal gesagt, man muss sich damit eigentlich nochmal gar nicht so gut auskennen. Das sagt dir einfach, man muss keine Juristin, kein Jurist sein. Es sagt dir der gesunde Menschenverstand. Wenn du da so ein Papier bekommst, wo ein Satz der Kommission steht, ähm
ähm der Schutz personenbezogener Daten muss gewährleistet sein. So, dann gehen die Minister daran und schreiben dazu
Um das Funktionieren des Binnenmarktes zu gewährleisten, ist es erforderlich, dass der freie Fluss personenbezogener Daten zwischen den Mitgliedsstaaten durch den Schutz des Individuums betreffend die Verarbeitung dessen persönlicher Daten,
beschränkt oder verboten wird. Im Klartext Datenschutz ist nur solange wichtig,
wie's der Wirtschaft nicht im Weg steht. Und wenn sowas, das hat das natürlich rechtlich nicht wirklich bindend, es sind einleitende Worte. Aber wenn sone Sätze da reinkommen, dann muss man sich doch mal fragen, mit wem haben die sich,
eigentlich unterhalten,
Da kommen wir wieder zurück zum Parlament. Äh wahrscheinlich haben die Minister oder die betreffenden Beamten, die für die Minister arbeiten, genau dieselben Leute konsultiert, die auch im Parlament jeden Tag ein und ausgehen.
Ja. Also das Parlament besteht bezieht sozusagen gerade so so ein politisches, habe ich so den Eindruck, ja, also das wird einfach geflutet.
Von der Gegenseite.
Von den Freundinnen äh Vorschlägen. Ähm was mich jetzt nochmal interessieren würde, weil ich das noch nicht so ganz verstanden habe, wenn jetzt
sowohl der, also es gab einen Vorschlag der Kommission, das Parlament berichtet jetzt äh entscheidet halt in einem langen Prozess, erst haben alle Ausschüsse was,
jetzt ist es an diesem Liebe-Ausschluss, ja
bürgerliche Freiheiten, Justiz und Inneres heißt er ja. Äh dann ist aber auch nochmal der Ministerrat berät über dasselbe, wer
entscheidet denn letztlich also was ist die letztlich äh entscheidende Versammlung, die jetzt wirklich über den ganzen Komplex,
Finale Wort spricht.
Dass der nächste Witz an der Sache. Die Entscheidung fällt mal wieder hinter verschlossenen Türen. Und zwar treffen sich nämlich alle drei Institutionen, also die Kommission, das Parlament,
und der Ministerrat treffen sich wieder, schicken Delegierte und verhandeln über Kompromisse.
Nach dem Parlament und Rat ihre Position festgelegt haben. Die Kommission hat ja schon äh einen eigenen Entwurf.
Kommission wird dann vermutlich da so ein bisschen in der Meinungsminderheit sein.
Je nachdem wie die Position vom Parlament und Rat,
derzeit noch in Beratung ist, ausfällt, genau, es könnte sein, dass dann im Endeffekt die Kommission für einen relativ äh starken Datenschutz eintritt,
Berichte des Parlaments, auch wenn's der grüne Jan-Philipp Albrecht ist, vom Parlament nur das Mandat hat, äh den in einigen Punkten zu verschlimmbessern und der Rat äh eine komplett grauenhafte Version wird. Das ist die Gefahr, genau.
Und deshalb ist halt unser Argument, dass wir gucken müssen, dass wir halt aus Parlament ein bisschen einwirken
weil beim Ministerrat, okay, wir haben jetzt den offenen Brief an Friedrich, ich will ihn auch nicht runterspielen, aber da ist es relativ schwer, die zu beeinflussen. Bei den Abgeordneten, da haben wir auch Erfahrung mit gemacht,
siehe acta, Erfolgsstory, ähm ist es schon ein bisschen einfacher. Und,
Auch nochmal gesagt, es macht schon Eindruck, wenn da E-Mails kommen,
Ich war selber, ich war selber im Parlament, Praktikant und wenn du da sitzt und jeden Tag fünfzig E-Mails zu irgendeinem Thema kommt, dann müssen sich nämlich genau die Praktikanten,
und Mitarbeiter mit diesen E-Mails beschäftigen, weil die natürlich beantwortet werden, außer natürlich irgendwelche unfreundlichen Nonnemessdinger
aber inhaltliche E-Mails werden da schon beantwortet. Dann fangen nämlich die Praktikanten an, in den anderen Büros zu fragen, habt ihr die E-Mail auch bekommen? Ja.
Was antworten wir dadrauf? Boah, keine Ahnung von dem Thema. Scheint aber irgendwie wichtig zu sein. Ach, für unsere Fraktion ist der oder die zuständig. Fragen wir mal die.
So, dann bekommen die so eine Standardantwort von den zuständigen in der Fraktion, die müssen die raussenden,
Was wir erreicht haben, ist oft, dass auf den Fluren des Parlaments darüber gequatscht wird. Das haben wir einfach erreicht und dass sich die äh Leute,
dass sich die Fraktion so weiter dadrüber den Kopf machen müssen und dann fangen nicht nur die Abgeordneten, die dafür zuständig sind, sondern auch die anderen Abgeordneten und ihre Mitarbeiter an nachzudenken, wow,
es scheint irgendwie wichtig zu sein und wenn die mir drohen, dass die mich nicht mehr wählen, weil ich grad ihren Datenschutz da absäge, denn,
Sollte man vielleicht da drum nochmal kümmern und dann sollte das vielleicht nicht ähm dieser eine Abgeordnete alleine machen oder ich sollte mal zumindestens mit dem reden, was da gerade läuft.
Was wäre denn dann deine konkrete Handlungsempfehlung jetzt? An die Hörer.
Handlungsempfehlungen ist ähm E-Mails und Postkarten schreiben auf der Seite NATE City Sense dort EU.
Pornokarten schreiben.
Pornokarten für die Freiheit.
Beziehungsweise E-Mails an die Abgeordneten schreiben. Das kann man, glaube ich, auch über die digitale Gesellschaftsseite machen,
Genau, man kann auch anrufen im Parlament,
und der einfachste Weg ähm was einfach mit copy paste funktioniert, ist glaube ich ähm ein bisschen Information dadrüber verbreiten. Wir haben immer noch eine total geringe Awareness in Deutschland,
über dieses wichtige Thema. Und da ähm hat der, das kommt ist ein bisschen,
Nicht so ganz klar, wer es gemacht hat. Ich glaube, es kam aus der Ecke von Max Schremps, diesem Euro versus Facebook Student. Der hat ein ganz schönes Kampagnenvideo gemacht, ähm was diese Datenschutzreform wirklich so in,
zwei, drei Minuten runterbricht, sowohl die inhaltlichen Schwerpunkte als auch diesen ganzen politischen Prozess, über den wir gerade eben sehr viel gesprochen haben,
und wenn man das seinen Freunden einfach mal in die Timeline packt, dann ja,
dann hat es glaube ich auch schon Einfluss. Dann haben wir den selben Effekt wie im Parlament. Wir spamen unsere Freunde ein bisschen und irgendwann fangen die dann an zu überlegen, wow, das muss ja wirklich irgendwie wichtig sein.
Ja, das werden wir dann mal verlinken das Video. Ich glaube, ich kenne das noch nicht, ist schon ist schon im Wordpress. Okay. Da muss ich mich nicht groß sorgen. Ja.
Das Thema wird uns noch ein Stück begleiten, aber gerade,
Also just in diesem Moment, in diesen Tagen äh laufen halt die zentralen Entscheidungen für die Parlamentsposition,
Auch die Ratsposition, aber da haben wir's schwieriger einzubinden und deswegen wollten wir nochmal, weil wir merken, dass Sascha Lobus Mutter es leider noch nicht aufm Schirm hat,
ähm dieses Thema auch hier nochmal entsprechend. Benjamin blockt da sehr viel darüber, aber das ist Text, das ist Netzpolitik ORG, das lesen wir Nerds,
diese Verordnung.
Regelt den.
Regelt den Datenschutz der kompletten EU für die Zukunft. Äh das wird wichtiger als das Bundesdatenschutz. Das äh wird in vielen Punkten das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz ersetzen,
Das wird extrem wichtig. Und jetzt fallen die Entscheidungen dazu,
Ist übrigens auch zwei äh geteilt. Das eine ist äh also es sind zwei Sachen, die da passieren. Das ein äh das eine ist die Verordnung für Unternehmen und Behörden,
gleichzeitig gibt's aber auch noch eine Richtlinie für den Polizei und Justizbereich. Die hat bisher noch nicht wirklich so viel Aufmerksamkeit erfahren wie die Verordnung,
aber um uns selber in den Arsch zu treten, kündige ich jetzt einfach mal an, dass die Gäste äh demnächst TM,
auch 'ne inhaltliche Ausarbeitung dazu macht, die liegt eigentlich schon seit Wochen, wenn nicht sogar Monaten in der Pipeline, aber da auch genau jetzt, das wird unmittelbar parallel zur Verordnung behandelt, dort auch die Weichen gestellt werden,
wollen wir auch darauf noch ein kleines bisschen Aufmerksamkeit lenken. Die EU regelt gerade den Datenschutz aller siebenundzwanzig Mitgliedsstaaten für die Zukunft.
Nur so auf einer Businessebene, sondern eben auch, was Behördentransaktionen betrifft.
Und wir können aber nächstes Jahr nicht so tun wie äh wo kommt denn das auf einmal her, wir sind dagegen, weil dann ist zu spät.
Ein bisschen wie Bestandsdatenauskunft, die außer aus dem Schatten herauskamen, aus der Schattenberichterstattung.
Fast.
Ja
Ja, um vielleicht nochmal einen Vergleich dazu machen, also wir haben ja im Moment so unwahrscheinliche Big Data-Euphorie. Überall an allen Ecken hören wir, boah, wir können irgendwas mit Daten machen. Das ist nützlich, das ist gut,
finden wir auch,
nur gleichzeitig muss man sich halt gucken, wer sind diese Akteure, die diese Euphorie verbreiten? Und ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, wir sind gerade an so einer Stelle, ähm
wie in den achtziger, neunziger Jahren, wo wir die Finanzmärkte unwahrscheinlich liberalisiert haben
Das ist uns irgendwann auf den äh auf die Füße gefallen, weil damals war eine Euphorie wow, wir können damit großartige Sachen machen, wir können aus wenig Geld mehr Geld machen
und so ähnlich finde ich, ist es jetzt auch. Ähm überall steht Daten sind das Öl des einundzwanzigsten Jahrhunderts. Die entsprechenden, die Firmen haben das schon im
offen Visier, klar, die lobbyieren in Brüssel und die versuchen sich da dafür ideale, deregulierte Märkte zu schaffen.
Und
wie gesagt ähm im einundzwanzigsten Jahrhundert sind uns dann die Banken auf die Füße gefallen und vielleicht werden uns dann später mal die Daten auf die Füße fallen, wenn wir jetzt unsere Datenmärkte ein schreckliches Wort äh deregulieren.
Jetzt musst du die Kommentare lesen.
Welche?
Die dann zu dem Blogpost äh eintrudeln werden.
Zu unserem ja klar mache ich auch, habe ich auch keine Angst vor.
Nee, ich meinte Benjamin.
Ach so, zum Westpolitik. Ja, mach mal.
Na ja gut, ich meine, dass da äh auch verschiedene Meinungen gibt. Das ist ja äh kein äh kein Geheimnis, nicht unbedingt jeder,
trägt jetzt, sagen wir mal so die klassische äh Datenschutzargumentation und da muss auch sicherlich ähm bewegt werden, ne,
also,
finde das ja auch, sagen wir mal vollkommen nachvollziehbar, dass wenn man jetzt in so einem politischen Entscheidungsposition ist, dass man, gerade, wenn man auch noch unter Dauerfeuer der Wirtschaft steht, dass man sich da sehr wohl auch darüber Gedanken machen muss und das jetzt nicht einfach auch nur die Losung sein kann, naja
nichts mehr an niemanden never äh äh überall. Ja, weil das,
Wird auch gar nicht funktionieren. Das ist, glaube ich, auch überhaupt nicht äh also nicht nur politisch nicht durchsetzbar, sondern einfach auch technisch nicht, nicht durchsetzbar und ähm von daher, weil's eben auch so ein sperriges Thema ist, ähm,
gehen die wahrscheinlich auch ganz schön unter in dieser ganzen Thematik.
Das aber nochmal gesagt, so schlimm ist es dann gar nicht. Dieser Kommissionsvorschlag äh stärkt im Grunde Datenschutzrecht, was seit Mitte der Neunziger durch die EU-Richtlinie gilt.
Das heißt, es sind kleine Tweets, wie wir immer sagen. Ähm,
bestehenden Datenschutzrecht. Eigentlich geht's nur darum, das mal vernünftig durchzusetzen und dass sich die Betreiber von Internetdiensten mal wirklich daran halten, dass dann halt, wenn ich mich da abgemeldet habe, auch meine Daten gelöscht sind. Und
Einwilligung der Nutzerin oder des Nutzers können die Firmen immer noch alles machen,
an den Kragen geht's eher nur denen, die da unter dem Radar schwimmen, die ähm,
Profile im Netz anlegen, diese ganzen tausend kleinen Firmen und Dienste, die kein Mensch kennt, die äh mich aber über alle größeren Webseiten im Netz verfolgen,
den geht's vielleicht so ein bisschen an den Kragen, weil die sind im Moment unter dem Radar, müssen nicht nach Zustimmung fragen. Aber alle,
sowieso schon nach Zustimmung fragen, die werden den größten Teil von dem, was sie machen und was auch gut ist, dass sie das machen. Ähm.
Werden das weitermachen dürfen,
sind kleine Tweets, es ist ganz klassische Verbraucherpolitik, da sollte man sich auch nicht in die Ecke drängen lassen und sagen, boah, das ist jetzt das super Aluhut Thema. Nein, ist es nicht,
Google, Facebook und GMX Freemay werden weiter existieren.
Und ich dachte schon es ist vorbei mit der Suche. Ja wenn man jetzt hier mal den äh den Themenhahn da an der Stelle ein bisschen drosseln. Mhm.
Pellon und äh ja dann können wir ja nochmal hier so auf ein paar abschließende Kurzmeldungen äh marschieren, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ne?
Ja, lasst uns ein paar kurze Meldungen machen, äh nachdem wir jetzt schon ziemlich harten Stoff haben, ich.
Ich schiebe trotzdem noch ein hartes Thema ein, einfach nur ab, weil's auch wichtig ist. Äh Benjamin schreibt immer zur Datenschutzverordnung, nicht acta, aber genauso wichtig. Ja, wir haben tatsächlich auch ein neues Akta.
Dass also zwei, aber nur eins, was uns unmittelbar betrifft, äh taff da.
Haben sie sich wieder ein neues neues Kürzel.
Genau. Das transatlantische Freihandelsabkommen taffter, manchmal auch unter dem Namen TTIP äh bezeichnet. Das ist dasselbe. Äh taff da finden wir besser,
Äh was war das hier? Die Süddeutsche hat das, glaube ich, mal als.
Warum findet ihr das besser? Weil's mir nach Acta klingt.
Ja und weil's auch äh zeigt, was es macht. Äh wir haben jede Menge äh also Tough da steht für Freihandelsabkommen.
Und CTIP.
Steht für,
und wir kennen durch äh NAFTA und andere Afters äh können wir taffa tatsächlich genau in die äh Tradition der Freihandelsabkommen,
stellen und die Süddeutsche, wie gesagt, dass man als Wirtschaftsnator bezeichnet. Also das was im Februar Obama und EU Kommission, glaube ich, angekündigt haben, äh ein gemeinsames Freihandelsabkommen,
Stärkung der Wirtschaft, Abbau der Handelshemmnisse zwischen äh ja transatlantik vor allem äh USA und EU.
Das wird auch derzeit verhandelt. Von der Kommission und USA und äh ja ähm äh,
Lobbygruppen, die den Zugang dazu haben und,
Ja, wahrscheinlich äh ist da auch Urheberrecht äh beziehungsweise geistiges Eigentum, wie Urüberrichte, Markenrechte, Patente und so weiter,
Teil von diesem äh Verhandlungsmandat, wo haben mehrmals angekündigt, befürchteten befürchten wir seit langem,
Letzte Woche hat das EU-Parlament eine Resolution zum Verhandlungsmandat der EU äh dazu gegeben. Auch die sagen, dass das geistige Eigentum da ruhig mal mit behandelt werden kann und das ist im Endeffekt genau das, was wir bei,
AGDA hatten eine internationalen äh Freihandelsabkommen. Da sitzen hinter verschlossenen Türen,
mal wieder Vertreter von mehr oder weniger demokratischen Institutionen delegiert, wie irgendwelche Abgeordneten der EU Kommission, wir wissen noch nicht mal genau, wer sagt uns ja niemand, wer dort genau sitzt
äh aber teilweise,
auch äh Lobbygruppen mit am Tisch verhandeln über den äh Handel, Handelsabkommen, Handelsbestimmungen,
von EU und Europa, aber unter anderem eben auch geistiges Eigentum.
Und und und äh die Meldung, dass das EU-Parlament äh ein Verhandlungs, also ein was er bisher beschlossen wurde, ist, ist das, dass man verhandelt.
Das wurde announced, das wurde nicht beschlossen. Äh das verhandelt wird, das haben EU-Kommissionen und äh USA, Außen- oder Wirtschaftsministerium, wer auch immer dafür verantwortlich ist, unter sich ausgemacht,
Jetzt hat das äh EU-Parlament auch eine Meinung dazu abgegeben. So, wenn ihr schon verhandelt, dann hätten wir gerne,
Bitte, bitte, dass ihr unsere äh ja Besorgnisse,
und Meinungen auch mit in die Verhandlung tragt. Also das Parlament hat so eher seine Meinung abgegeben letzte Woche. Die Verhandlungen laufen schon äh länger. Die Idee gibt's auch schon mehr als zehn Jahre,
ähm announct wurde die Verhandlungen im Februar. Aber das Problem ist wie bei ActA,
da ist eben genau die, nicht nur die Parallele, das sagt's geistige Eigentum da drin ist, sondern auch wir wissen nicht, wer da verhandelt, wir wissen nicht wann wo verhandelt wird, wir wissen nicht, was verhandelt wird bis irgendwann zum Schluss ein Abkommen, ein offizielles Abkommen präsentiert wird,
wie bei Acta,
dann heißt hier, friss oder stirb. Im Übrigen sind da unten im klein gedruckten auch unsere äh ja Vorstellungen von, wie das mit den geistigen Eigentum,
geregelt werden sollte. Und die, ja, Befürchtung ist, dass das eben nicht gerade zu unseren Gunsten ausfällt.
Hätte mir vom Parlament wenigstens gewünscht, dass die sagen ja ihr könnt gerne verhandeln, aber wir wollen vollkommen eine Transparenz haben und wir wollen mitreden,
Das hat sich das Parlament nicht getraut irgendwie.
Auf jeden Fall, wir wissen noch nicht, was da drin steht. Ist ja geheim, aber wir sollten das auf dem Schirm haben äh und äh Markus und ähnliche Leute haben schon öfters mal Interesse, ein Mikrofone gesagt, also geistiges Eigentum sollte da ausgeklammert werden.
Was heißt denn das? Das Parlament hat sich nicht getraut. Welcher Teil des Parlamentes hat sich denn da nicht getraut? Ist das jetzt auch wieder hier so diese klassische äh konservativ Liberal gegen.
Sozialistengruppen oder ist das eher so 'ne nationale Splitung?
Das war nee, das die Abstimmung des Plenums letzte Woche waren äh Liberale und Konservative waren für diesen äh Beschluss,
dass der sagt, bitte verhandelt und geistiges Eigentum darf und soll auch Teil davon sein.
Und auch Geheimbitte.
Äh wir würden gern so viel Transparenz wie möglich haben, bitte. So ungefähr steht da drin, also ja genau.
Ja, genau. Mhm.
Ähm ich glaube auch große Teile der Sozialdemokraten haben das mitgetragen. Die meisten der Linken und der Grünen waren dagegen, wenn auch nicht alle. Die hatten auch teilweise eigene,
Vorschläge, die dann aber nicht angenommen worden sind.
Nur als kurze Meldung, schon wieder viel zu viel gequatscht. Äh taffer läuft. Und die Gefahr ist, dass das tatsächlich ein neues ActA wird.
Okay, mal wieder eine neue Abkürzung, die man.
Ja, wir haben auch noch eine. TPP. Das ist nochmal dasselbe, nur nicht in transatlantisch, sondern in transparzifisch.
Das läuft tatsächlich schon 'ne ganze Weile zwischen Nordamerika, Südamerika und ein Pazifikstaaten da wir genug damit zu tun haben alle Bundesländer, Deutschland und Europa zu beobachten,
haben wir das so ein bisschen der IFF und anderen Organisationen überlassen, poste ich gleich mit in das Wordpress,
auch das wird derzeit verhandelt und davor warnt die IFF auch mit einem lustigen Erklärbär Video.
Wird verlinkt.
Okay, wird verlinkt.
So, wollen wir noch ein bisschen Spaß zum Schluss? Es ist nicht alles so trocken, so hardcore, ne, wenn der Linus nicht da ist, dann wird das immer so so detailliert und nicht so lustig.
Ja, ja klar, wir können jetzt auch zum unterhaltsamen Teil äh der Sendung kommen.
Ulberechtsrolle.
Urheberrecht.
Ja, du musst jetzt bald äh Software auf deinem Mac installieren, die überprüft, ob du äh ja, ob alle deine urheberrechtlich geschützten Werke, ob du die auch legal benutzen darfst und wenn nicht,
Dann wird so der Bildschirm gesperrt und du musst irgendwie.
Das sagt das sagt die US-Entertainment Industrie und zwar eine lustige gibt mir eine Minute,
Eine lustige Institution namens die Commission.
IP Commission. Das ist überhaupt äh die haben ich fange mal von vorne an. Das ist eine lustige Organisation. Habe ich vorher noch nie gehört. IP-Commission.
Und die setzen sich zusammen aus,
einer von Intel, der ehemalige US äh also ist eine amerikanische Organisation, der ehemalige äh was heißt Ambassador, Botschafter,
USA in China,
so ein paar und deren Mission ist es, also die haben halt irgend so 'ne Lobbyorganisation gegründet und die haben deren Organisation hat drei Ziele,
Sie wollen den, dass den Diebstahl und den Raub vom geistigen Eigentum untersuchen, quantifizieren.
Was China damit zu tun hat.
Und dann äh angemessene äh gesetzliche Regelungen und Bestrafungen dagegen unternehmen. Und die haben jetzt so einen Lust.
Sagen wir mal so konform mit der aktuellen Feindbildlage argumentieren, ja? Mhm.
Der sagt, das ist alles noch viel schlimmer, als wir das vorgestellt haben und die Chinesen sind überall und die klauen unser geistiges Eigentum, das Öl des einundzwanzigsten Jahrhunderts.
Deswegen müssen wir jetzt auch, dass tun dürfen, was die Chinesen auch alle die ganze Zeit machen, nämlich böses, überall installieren, damit wir überhaupt noch eine Chance haben, unsere Copyrights Geschichten durchzusetzen.
Genau, sie hätten gerne so einen lustigen.
Software, die auf.
Nach dem Motto äh interessiert uns nicht, dass Soni da vor ein paar Jahren äh ordentlich hat für einstecken müssen, dass sie irgendwie so äh ein Trojaner mit auf den Rechner geschoben haben. Wir hätten das jetzt gerne einfach mal legalisiert.
Ja genau, die schreiben auch dazu so also ich weiß nicht, ob das Wort Soni fällt, aber sie stellen sich direkt in diese Tradition und diese paar Leute, von denen auch manche tatsächlich juristische Erfahrungen haben, schreiben, ja, so eine Software,
das ginge gerade noch so legal unter amerikanischen Recht und deswegen hätten wir das gern.
Welchem amerikanischen Recht, dem Ausnahmegesetzen im Kriegszustand oder den.
Wegesisting, keine Ahnung, welche Gesetze das sind.
Na ja vielleicht die, die in Guantanamo gelten.
Ja aber sie sagen dann auch, was nicht geht, ist, sie sie würden ja auch gern die äh entsprechend Urheberrecht verletzenden Dateien auch einfach mal löschen und so, aber das geht dann leider noch nicht äh unter existierenden äh Gesetzen.
Was kommt als nächstes?
Ja, als nächstes.
Nippelclips, mit Stromstößen irgendwie, die direkt seinen Laptop angeschlossen werden irgendwie. So als Instantanbestrafung.
Also Sony ist das eine, was da sofort äh in den Kopf kommt, Sony hatte Rotkids mit Audio-CDs ausgeliefert, ähm.
Das war schon echt Hardcore.
Die sind da für, ich weiß nicht, ob sie dafür verklagt worden sind und verurteilt worden sind. Sie haben das dann gestoppt, aber ich glaube eher auf öffentlichen Druck und nicht auf äh einer konkreten Klage. Müsste man aber nochmal äh.
Recherchieren, da weiß ich auch nicht wie es ausgegangen ist, auf jeden Fall ist das so ein Imageschaden, den sie da sich abgeholt haben, den will jetzt auch nicht unbedingt jeder haben.
Ja, aber in anderen Bereichen ist es doch ganz normal. Also ich war ich glaube, ihr seid einfach nur nicht in dieser Filter-Bubble, aber bei diesen ganzen Computerspielen läuft es doch de facto
oder so. Ich hatte irgendwie neulich den äh kleinen Bruder von meiner Freundin zu Gast und habe irgendwie im Media Markt, habe mir irgendwie so ein altes FIFA geklärt und wollte es auf den Computer von meiner Freundin installieren, seit langem mal wieder an einem Windows-Computer gesessen und dann ähm,
dich erstmal, um dieses Spiel zu spielen, muss man halt auch noch so eine Begleitsoftware installieren, so was ähnliches wie Steam,
Nur halt äh für EA Games, das heißt, bei denen irgendwie ein bisschen anders.
Also das Team, dass dieser Onlineshopping für Games äh.
Genau, also halt um FIFA zu starten, dieses Fußballspiel musst du diesen extra installieren und dieser extra Klein, das sagt er dir auch relativ ähm
gut, du wirst also gut informiert, machst einen Explus
dass ähm dass der, der, dass der auf deinem Rechner guckt, ob du nicht ähm,
Copyright Scheiße drauf hast, also ob du nicht schon mal ob da nicht ein gecracktes EA Spiel oder so drauf ist, also das ist in so in diesem Gamesbereich ist das ganz normal.
Stimmt, die gehen ja auch dazu über immer eine Internetverbindung, selbst für Offline-Games zu fordern, um eben mit den zentralen Servern kommunizieren zu können, was sind neue Hash-Listen von verbotener Software und wir melden das dann natürlich zentral, welche Software du installiert hast.
Genau in dieser Gamerlobby ist das halt nicht Gamer Lobby bei den Gamern, ist das halt ganz normal, nur was ich sagen wollte, die haben halt in dem Sinne keine Lobby, beziehungsweise da, gibt's, glaube ich, auch wieder diese berühmte einfach nicht.
Die sitzen alle vorm Bildschirm und schreien, ich will ein.
Da ist ihnen dann egal, was installiert wird. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen schade. Hm.
Man kann sehen, Benjamin liest Datenschutzerklärungen. Aber ich glaube, die lustige IP-Commission.
Hast du noch andere Hobbys?
Ich glaube, die IP-Kommission, die hätte das gerne allgemeiner, nicht nur mit spezifischer Software, die ausgeliefert wird, sondern so äh in general per Deefolk auf jeder Windows.
Einfach mal alle mal so überwachen und so. Hm.
Genau und ähnlich lustige Sachen hören wir aus der Schweiz,
Also ich äh zur Einordnung, ich glaube und hoffe, mein gesundes Menschen und USA Bild sagt, dass es nur eine bescheuerte Lobby und das wird niemals eine Chance haben äh zu einem Gesetz.
In der Schweiz äh sind blöde Forderungen, tatsächlich ein kleines bisschen konkreter.
Und zwar gibt's da in der im Justizministerium eine Arbeitsgruppe.
Optimierung der kollektiven Verwertung von Urheberrechten und Verwandtenschutzmaßnahmen? Und die haben offenen Treffen äh Anfang Mai,
auch ein paar Vorschläge zum Urheberrecht gemacht,
unter anderem, also so einmal, was soll hier so ein schönes Zitat, einmal die ganzen schlechten, das Schlimmste aus Frankreich, den USA und Deutschland kombiniert.
Also wir wollen einmal Netzsperren gegen.
Optimierung der kollektiven Verwertung von Urheberrechten. Und Verwandten, Schutzrechten, was sind denn die Verwandtenschutzrechte von Urheberrechten?
Ja, das sind dann so Leistungsschutzrechte und sowas.
Ähm genau, sie wollen unter anderem Netz sperren gegen Urheberrechtsverstöße.
Wow, der aktuell.
Ja, die Schweiz hat zwar kein Gesetz, zu Netzsperren,
Die haben aber so mehr oder weniger freiwillige Vereinbarungen, also auch ohne Verträge, wie Ursula von der Leyen das damals machen wollte, vor dem Gesetz. Äh die zwei großen Provider, die machen einfach mal Netzsperren von so einer Filterliste.
Äh der.
Die machen das jetzt schon.
Die machen das jetzt schon gegen, aber gegen äh Kindesmissbrauchsdokumentationen. Äh.
Ach so, das ist sozusagen nur für das Gute sozusagen.
Genau, das gute TM beziehungsweise Kindesmissbrauchsdokumentationen und äh es gibt da auch noch zwei, drei ähm Gerichtsbeschlüsse,
auch einzelne Seiten sperren. Das ist aber ziemlich schweizbetifft, also irgendwie Apple, OPler dot org, äh,
weiß überhaupt nicht, was dahinter ist, aber das hat nichts mit Kindesmissbrauchsdokumentation zu tun. Das ist aber die übliche, wenn die Strukturinfrastruktur immer da ist,
sagen natürlich auch Gerichte, ja, jetzt habt ihr keine Ausrede mehr, äh auch diese Seite, wo sich Person X voller mitfühlt.
Und wer soll da ähm nach diesem Modell äh die entscheidende ähm Instanz sein, die solche Sperlisten definiert.
Die sogenannte Cobik, die das jetzt schon macht, das ist die schweizerische Koordinationsstelle zur Bekämpfung der Internetkriminalität,
und die sammeln jetzt schon, es gibt ja so ein EU-Verbund von äh Polizeibehörden, die Filterlisten mit Kindesmissbrauchsdokumentation im Internet äh zusammenstellen,
und die sind mit den nationalen Behörden unter anderem der Cobik ziemlich eng in Kontakt und die melden das schon bisher an ja
die Provider, die dann sperren. Und da sollen jetzt eben auch äh offensichtlich illegale Quellen, was auch immer das ist,
die urheberrechte Verletzung mit aufgenommen werden.
Ja, das erinnert mich, dass wir sozusagen immer noch kein äh funktionierendes Korrespondentennetzwerk in den in der Schweiz aufgebaut haben.
Je kleiner. Lass uns das mal.
Genau. Ich habe da auch schon mal gehört, dass wir mal jemand haben, aber wir müssen mal sozusagen mal in gehen.
Aber wir hatten heute schon zwei Gäste und der dritte, der schon.
Ja, nee, nee, das muss ja jetzt nicht gleich sofort sein, aber perspektivisch müssen wir, glaube ich, auch mal die Schweiz ein wenig in den Fokus nehmen, weil da sind ja auch jeden Fall auch ausreichend idiotische Ideen in der Welt.
Genau, unter anderem wollen sie natürlich auch äh.
Und äh Provider sollen angeblich offensichtlich illegale Inhalte,
ziemlich schnell mit runternehmen und sonst rechtlich dafür verantwortlich werden. Die Sachen wie das im Endeffekt aussieht, haben wir schon oft genug mit dem DMCA gesehen. Also da wird im Zweifel eher zu viel als zu wenig weggenommen.
Weil gibt ja auch kein Gericht,
gerichtliche Prüfung vorher ist jetzt was illegal oder nicht, sondern Firmen scannen halt im Auftrag der äh Verwertungsgesellschaften das Netz und da fallen dann so Listen,
raus, wo unter anderem dann irgendwie der TPP AFK der,
zäh lizenzierte Film auch mal mit gesperrt wird, weil hat irgendwie ja der Filter angeschlagen.
Einmal, einmal das Schlimmste aus Frankreich, Deutschland und den USA.
Will eine Arbeitsgruppe des Justizministeriums der Schweiz. Mal sehen, ob die damit durchkommen. Ich hoffe nicht.
Und unsere Schweizer Korrespondenten auch nicht.
Meine Herren, ey. Das ist irgendwie äh ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn sie morgen nochmal äh,
Initiative für die Imagente Verhinderung von Internet äh Libertät äh losbringen. Evil.
Wo sozusagen,
einfach mal alles, alles drin ist, dass er irgendwie schon jemals in solchen Gesetzen eingerührt haben so, von irgendwie Installation bis hin,
Ja, Hausarrest irgendwie auf Knopfdruck und so weiter, das einfach zu Hause sofort die Gitter runterfallen, wenn irgendwie auch nur das falsche der falsche Link angeklickt wurde.
Ist noch einiges zu zu leisten,
Und was bleibt? Was steht an? Was ist äh der Ausblick? Ihr seid viel in Europa äh unterwegs. Wird euch der Weg demnächst einmal wieder nach Brüssel oder ähm.
Eher so seltener Ausflüge.
War es eher so ein seltener Ausflug, weil das ja auch immer so ein Finanzierungsproblem ist. Und für dieses Barcamp von Edri gab's dann mal Mittel, aber die Rege ist das nicht. Und zum Beispiel, ich glaube
ähm dieser einen Fördertopf, den die angezapft haben für die Datenschutzreform, der ist jetzt, glaube ich, auch alle.
Also ein akutes Unterfinanzierungsproblem.
Wichtig da kommt halt viel her was dann hier wo es dann hier heißt wo kommt das denn auf einmal her und jetzt können wir aber eigentlich gar nichts mehr dran ändern.
Ja. Wie läuft's denn jetzt eigentlich hier mit dem äh Spendentopf für Netzpolitik Org?
Die Spendenkampagne von Netzpolitik hat von den angepeilten fünfzigtausend, die das Projekt im jedes Jahr quasi auch im aktuellen Jahr Verlust macht,
jetzt sechsundzwanzigtausend Euro per Crowdfunding eingenommen. Das ist die Hälfte und das ist quasi haben wir vom laufenden Jahr zwanzig dreizehn bis zum Juni,
soweit finanziert, dass wir 'ne schwarze Null haben,
freuen uns jetzt, wenn möglichst viel äh von Spenden auch auf äh Daueraufträge überführt werden,
vor allem direkt auf Konto, geht aber auch PayPal und das ganze Zeug, aber direkt Konto hat irgendwie die wenigsten Gebühren, die die ja ist am einfachsten,
zu händeln.
Und dann datenschutzfreundlichsten.
Genau, weil die Bank kriegt das ohnehin mit, ob man's über nochmal über Paypal oder Flatter piept oder nicht. Also,
sind jetzt nach sechs Wochen nicht die die erhofften fünfzigtausend drin. Äh die Hälfte. Vielen Dank an alle Spenderinnen und Spender und wir würden uns freuen
Wenn ja, wenn einige Leute, die dadrauf Bock haben, die das Projekt Netzpolitik ORG mögen, äh sich auch überlegen, eventuell einen kleinen Dauerauftrag, ob das jetzt ein oder zehn Euro ist, äh einzurichten.
Genau, oder so eine kleine, falls ja auch nicht jeder einfach zweimal drauf klicken und so und dann kann man dann einfach jeden Monat sein Autoklick ausführen lassen.
Ja, cool.
Gut, dann äh haben wir's wahr? Super. Benjamin, vielen Dank,
Danke auch nochmal hier an Johannes, den wir schon äh rausgeschmissen haben. Und ja, danke Andre hier. Nächste Woche geht's dann weiter hoffentlich mit Dinos, wenn ihr aus der Diaspora wieder äh zurückkehrt. Vielleicht bleibt er auch da, wer weiß?
Kein Problem, erstmal habe ich endlich Thomas wieder überholt. Hier haben wir hier so ein kleines Battle am Laufen.
Und dann fahren wir jetzt alle zusammen raus zu Linus in den Schlamm, oder? So, wir sagen tschüss. Ciao. Ciao, ciao.
Okay, alles klar. Brauchst nur den Schlamm. So, wir sagen tschüss, bis bald. Tschau, tschau.
Ciao. Ciao ciao.